it was a display of strength and a
reflection of what still needs to be
done even though the city is in
artillery range president zielinski
arrived for a Victory lap of Central
Square the moment is very important that
is the biggest the biggest city what was
occupied it since 24th of uh you know
February so that is the biggest city and
now it's free so Ukraine came so I'm
happy
the Russians may have been forced to
retreat in a humiliating defeat here but
the war still looms Darkly over this
city
it has been relatively quiet here over
the last few days but it's interesting
on the day that President zielinski
arrived in the city it's been much more
active
now the Russian positions are just the
other side of the danipro river and
we've heard the sound of a lot of
outgoing Ukrainian fire
and shells are also landing on the
outskirts of the city
The Liberation of Curson which only a
few months ago Vladimir Putin annexed
and declared as Russian forever has
given this country a major boost and
what's happened is still sinking in
what does liberation mean to you uh
you know the word Freedom right now
means a lot for us
just
there was like eight months of
I don't know I don't know how to explain
you know fear of
fear of our lives but living is
extremely hard and at the local markets
the prices keep going up
vladim Arena are struggling to provide
for their baby
is
at the beginning of the of the end of
the war it's a bit about this long way
this war to the best heroes of our
country president zelenski is correct
when he says there is still a long way
to go
[Music]
liberation of a major city is definitely
something many areas of the country
though still remain under occupation
Alex Rossi Sky News Kirsten